PROFESSOR 1: So I think
in a course like this,
assessment is tricky.
That these are individual
clients and projects.
And we can try to
standardize maybe
the design and engineering
challenge to some extent,
but that's not
necessarily what we took
as our primary consideration.
We really started
with the people
first, and tried to
match people to projects.
And there's no doubt, there
are some projects that
are more technically involved.
There are some projects
where the logistics are
more difficult--
meeting with the client
or even working with him or
her, or even within the team.
So it is a tricky kind of thing.
But I think having us as
instructors, very involved
in the class, and getting a
sense of all of the projects,
having the mentors really
have a strong understanding
of different
projects' progress--
so we had one mentor
for every two teams--
was really key to the
assessment at a high level.
We had different pieces over
the course of the semester.
So doing this
mid-term design review
counts as part of
the assessment.
Certainly the final
presentations,
the documentation is a big part.
But we also rely on mentor
feedback, client feedback--
we met with all the clients
at the end of the semester.
As well as peer feedback.
This is a team-based
project course.
So taking in all
these inputs is what
we tried to do when
it came to assessment.
To really try to understand
what students had learned
and how they performed
in the course.
GRACE: So for some of these
we did prepare rubric,
or we had a vague sense of
what we were looking for.
So for example,
for the blog posts,
we would score it
based on not just
how well did you
write it, and grammar,
and how much
information is there,
but we were looking for really
deep, personal reflection.
And so that's what we gave
distinctiveness points for,
I believe.
And so, for example,
you could have
a post just on assistive
dogs, and what types
of assistive dogs are there.
Which is great, it shows
that a student is learning.
But another post-- one of
my favorite posts, actually,
over the semester-- was
from one of my students
who was struggling
with, should I
go into assistive
technology as a career
when everyone is
saying you should
do something that's lucrative.
But this is beneficial.
But what if beneficial isn't
profitable, what happens then?
And she was really
struggling with,
am I a selfish person,
things like that.
And so that kind of very
deep, personal growth
is something that
I valued a lot.
We all valued a lot.
There's actually
very little weight
put on the final project.
We put a lot of weight
on how well did they
go about the design process.
And so, how many prototypes
did they manage to do?
When they didn't have the
skills to do a certain project,
were they able to go
look for resources?
Did they go around
MIT knocking on doors,
asking professors for help,
asking machine shop technicians
for help?
That was also highly valued.
What else do you
think I'm missing out?
We also took into account
when the clients were-- so,
some clients would
change their mind
about what project they
wanted the students to work on
over the course of semester.
Which is really difficult
for the students,
because they would make
progress on something
and then have to change the
project direction completely.
And so we would try and take
that into account as well.
Like, how were the students
able to manage that?
And so because of these
kind of little things,
we really didn't
put a lot of weight
on how the project turned
out at the end of the day.
It was more about
how much effort
did you put into it, how much
did you grow as a person,
how well did you manage
your clients' expectations,
and were you able to
satisfy the client given
all the constraints.
So very, very organic.
Which is why we
had to spread out
the grading rubric across
lots of little components.
And that's why we
had to get feedback
from mentors, and
peers, and clients,
and have mid-semester reviews
and final semester reviews.
I hope I explained that.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah,
I think there's
a lot of aspects to this.
One is, we really did try
to structure the evaluation
as much as possible in
terms of being able to try
to grade objectively.
And so we did have a decent
number of structured rubrics,
that we're happy
to share, in terms
of how we evaluated different
components of the project.
So everything from the course,
everything from the blog posts,
to the videos, to the
mid-semester and final semester
panels, the documentation,
all aspects of the class.
I think for the
individual components,
as Grace says, really
trying to personalize
the learning a little bit in
terms of having reflections
or blog posts where people
could write about topics
that interested
them, as it related
to assistive technology.
I think that's something that
we tried this year, as opposed
to maybe more formed lab reports
on some of the labs that we did
or something like that.
The other part I think
we tried this year
was really to take in,
as Grace was saying,
all of these human
inputs or feedback.
So we met weekly as a staff,
and reflected on the projects
and the students' progress.
We talked to clients and
had students themselves talk
a little bit about their peers.
And so that's, I think, what
we tried to take into account.
To some extent we tried
to start from what
would be ideal in terms
of understanding students'
experiences in the class.
And that, I think,
makes it a little bit
tricky to evaluate or grade.
But hopefully it was
one reasonable way,
or one valuable way to do it.